So we're now beginning to
make our complete study
of rigid body motions
about fixed axis.
Let's consider something
like a bicycle wheel.
Here's the center of
mass of the wheel.
And our bicycle wheel--
the center of mass
has some velocity.
And here's ground.
And the reference frame
is the ground frame.
Now if the bicycle
wheel is rolling,
then there will be some type of
rotational motion of the wheel.
So you can imagine a point
on the rim is rotating.
And so what we have here
is a angular velocity
of this bicycle,
which we'll write
like this, our vector omega.
And we'll use our
right hand rule
to establish that
direction for omega.
And now in this
reference frame, we
have translational motion
of the center of mass.
And we have rotational motion
around the center of mass.
If we go to the center
of mass reference frame--
so if you want just a
little cartoon to show that,
here's your observer.
And your observer
is moving with VCM.
And so in that frame, the
center of mass is at rest,
and the only thing
we have is rotation
about the center of mass.
And so in this
picture, our motivation
will be that the total external
force causes the center of mass
to accelerate.
And that's how we can figure
out the center of mass motion.
And in this picture,
we no longer
have to consider
translational motion.
And what we'll study
and learn to analyze
is just pure rotation
about the center of mass--
so torque will produce
angular acceleration.
We can talk about
the rotational energy
about the center of mass.
And so we'll begin our
analysis of rotational motion
of translation and rotation
by focusing our interest
in the center of mass
frame-- so we've just
isolated the rotational motion.